you guys ready to go in some dark
territory yeah man did you guys see that
commercial that was glorifying
euthanasia where the woman was like I
can choose to die and then like they're
all dancing around or whatever
she didn't want to die
she wanted to live but they wouldn't
give her the care she needed so she
could live so she opted to die instead
because the state is California I'm
sorry this is Canada I don't mean like
the United States I mean like the
government state said well we can't give
you the adequate Health Care you need
but we can't kill you and she said fine
from the National Post woman featured in
pro-euthanasia commercial wanted to Live
Safe friends quote I feel like I'm
falling through the cracks so if I'm not
able to access health care am I then
able to access death care hatch said in
a CTV interview
so when they did the commercial showing
this woman about how she wanted to die
because she had a connective tissue
disorder what they omitted from that was
that she had given interviews and that
her friends had pleaded to give her the
care she needed because she didn't want
to die
now in Canada they're currently having a
debate over whether or not to extend
euthanasia to children so uh
you know this morning when I see the
project Veritas stuff I'm like oh I'm
gonna put on some 90s commercials I'm
gonna do it tomorrow too just zone out
and be like ah yeah cheeseburgers for 50
cents what do you guys think about
assisted suicide what about you what do
you think Scott well in regards to the
story I just think it's disgusting that
it's cheaper to kill someone to than to
keep them alive and I think that's what
it comes down to money
and uh you know we've seen that from
everything from Pharmaceuticals you know
the trying to get rid of competition
because if it means that there's a
cheaper solution to keep somebody alive
affects somebody's pocketbooks they're
willing to try to destroy that
competition which is going to make
people pay more in order to to stay
alive I just think it's all together
disgusting it's like the government has
an invested interest in in killing
people and depopulating them and making
sure that they no longer exist it's like
almost everything they do and they
incentivize goes down this one very dark
path uh the The Daily Caller has a very
interesting article that's headlined
euthanasia is now a leading cause of
death in Canada yeah three three percent
three percent of all deaths in Canada
were people being killed by the state
you know at what point is it genocide
so that's a good question
well it's a question that I think a lot
of people should be asking themselves
the world is just upside down you know I
I recently had a health scare
very ill went to the hospital and
because I've been Frugal because I've
saved every cent because
um I'm with Mom and Dad I'm in a 2005
Honda Civic I'm not living the lap of
luxury and because that I haven't spent
every cent I'm actually being penalized
for that where if my bank account said
zero dollars than I would be getting
better health care than being a
responsible physical Citizen and it just
uh every aspect of our society we seem
to reward irresponsibility and we reward
uh not having accountability and
transparency
unemployment is exactly that they'll say
don't get a job or you'll lose your your
free money so don't get a job as soon as
you get a job you lose your unemployment
check so there's no incentive yeah and
then you're you're watching and you're
saying oh I can't make this much money
because then I won't receive government
assistance and there's no incentive to
better your life why should I I'm going
to be taken care of
it they use tribal life used to be much
more hard I would I mean they would if
you couldn't walk you're there they
leave you on the ground as they all have
to travel on to find food somewhere else
you can't keep up sorry grandpa or
whatever maybe they throw in the back of
a wagon but if you're just gonna eat
lettuce and just waste our the tribe's
food and not contribute at some point
like harsh reality takes over but now
we're in a society where like people are
severely obese severely uh unhealthy
depressed not even contributing to
society because they're so depressed and
they're still like trying to support
those people and have those people breed
and like make more of that it feels like
no they're doing the opposite of that
they're trying to make sure that they
don't breed that they don't have
families that they don't reproduce that
they get eliminated but people get money
for having more kids more Social
Security and stuff or more um yeah
government problems tax benefits it
depends on what jurisdiction you're in
depends on what state you're in and it's
just enough to keep you floating but but
never enough to prosper just to keep you
dependent on on the government but I
mean that's what they what they want a
Ubi and in some senses in some
jurisdictions they already have that but
what they're doing in Canada seems
absolutely Draconian seems absolutely I
would even go as far as to say evil uh
there's a new bill C7 that wants to
allow miners to be able to be euthanized
by state Doctors Without The consent of
their parents that's literally the laws
that they're trying to pass there and
they're they're ruling that mentally ill
minors are legally allowed to uh be you
know euthanized against the will of
their parents so
um especially with mental health being
so just I want you guys
you know we've seen this stuff with
Florida with the parental rights and
education
imagine it's either you or someone you
know or just a third party
kid doesn't come home from school
parents get worried
14 year old teenage girl or something
so they call the police they call the
school the school says uh we don't we
don't have anything to tell you we're
sorry we say what what's going on well
we don't know they call the police the
police are like okay we'll look into it
the next day I was someone from the
school from the administration with the
police show up knock on the door and say
we didn't want to tell you this
yesterday because it's none of your
business but yesterday your child opted
for medical assistance and dying and we
assisted your child in going to the
doctor receiving a device which killed
them which assisted them in their own
death
you can go claim the body
I mean talk I know you've said like the
the violence of like watching kids get
sterilized against their parents will
watching a kid get killed against their
parents like without their parents I
mean that's complete topsy-turvy insane
if you look I know this is Canada but
with the Veritas stuff we saw last night
was probably it was probably one of the
most shocking things I have ever heard
it's bad enough we see these books like
we got genderqueer sent on the table Ian
bought it and you look at the images in
this and you're like Amazon says this
book is for adults only but they're
giving it to grade school kids and
putting it in their Library
then you hear from Veritas a guy
bragging about how he's got adult
objects for children with explanations
of how to spit on them to insert them
and things like that and as soon as I
heard that I said
you can come to me with any political
Theory political story but if you don't
think that we're headed towards some
kind of civil conflict then I would just
say you're wrong it's one thing when Joe
Biden weaponizes the doj sure it's
overtly political but when you hear a
story like what came out of veritas or
when you hear these stories about what's
going on in Canada they want to
euthanize children without alerting the
parents quite literally the state the
government of Canada is proposing
they're debating whether or not they can
take your child without telling you and
kill them what's the name of that bill
again B Bill C7
killed your kid in a way the government
wants and Canada wants to kill your
child I'm open I know sorry just I know
Canada is not the United States but I'm
saying we are dangerously close to that
line where where people are just going
to say nope
I'm open to like assisted suicide I
always have kind of been like if someone
wants to kill themselves they're gonna
do it I mean Maybe not maybe not people
have been brought back from the edge but
for my buddy hung himself during covid
you know wrecked me but whatever it's
still wrecking me right now
um if but no one could I don't think
anyone could have stopped him he wanted
he was he was finished and uh but the
kid to do it to a kid especially someone
on a pharmaceutical drug that's already
depressed do you know about the
documentary on the Golden Gate Bridge
we've talked about it before uh yeah
yeah every single person who survived
jumping off the Golden Gate Bridge said
as soon as they jumped they regretted
jumping and they realized that all of
their problems in life could have been
solved except having just jumped off the
Golden Gate Bridge
they were happy to be alive
most people who get past the depression
and suicide are happy to be alive it is
temporary it can be you can be saved the
government they said this in 2017 they
could save 140 million dollars by
killing people instead of treating them
this is the nightmare scenario of
government Health Care the system has to
be paid for somehow the system gets
strained people aren't getting there's
there's long lines there's complaints
people start protesting and they say
okay we need to figure out how to free
up the system I got it
we just kill people
that's what Canada is doing to save
money and treat people they will kill
those this is like
it's it's it's it's a governmental
Darwinism
well think about or Eugenics or democide
another way of you know saying it sorry
go ahead no just think about covid you
know we had doctors who were saying that
we shouldn't be treating patients who
are suffering from covid because they
didn't make the choice to get the
vaccine and you know similar to what we
saw with the censorship from Twitter I
think it's really no different who is in
control is going to be deciding who gets
benefited from the government and same
for what we were talking about earlier
with the Britney decision the Marine
wasn't chosen the American loving
freedom fighting Marine was discarded
over the gay black woman basketball
player because it was decided by the
government that that person was more
important than the other person and
that's exactly what we would see from
government decided Health Care you know
just think about a young person versus
an old person if they made the decision
why why would they choose to give the
kidney to the older person because they
would probably say oh they've got less
Life to Live they've got less value they
already did that here in the United
States when it came to deciding who's
going to get care based on their skin
color in Houston people were denied
life-saving treatment because they
weren't black because they were they
weren't in The Stereotype they weren't a
minority according to the group and they
were saying well too bad you're you're a
young male and you can't get this
treatment which is absolutely insane
this is why I'm going to open a hotel
that's going to have four floors and
each is a suite and each one is a is a
decade the 90s the 80s the 70s and the
60s and you'll go in like the 90s hotel
and everything's from the 90s you turn
the TV on it's good old 90s TV and you
can forget about all of the insanity
just plug into this this fake world the
windows will have TVs instead of windows
so yeah it's not real steak
it is it will be real steak it tastes
real but it's not real the pizza box
from the 90s from Pizza Hut and the
Pizza Hut guy shows up with a smile on
his face 30 minutes or it's free and he
hands you a little booket thing for your
kid I'm making a matrix reference you
know Cipher was like why would you go
back into the real world when you can
live in The Matrix and taste this
delicious steak and they're like because
it's not real in The Matrix you're just
you know but you know and then what
we'll do is we'll actually we'll build a
big complex unlike 50 acres and we'll
create a 90s City just so that like
think about it you know only landlines
no cell phones yeah yeah no no no I mean
your phone will work because you're
there but it'll be like a theme park and
you'll go in and everything's 90s it'll
be like walking into a 90s downtown
there'll be like a TV store there'll be
cassette tapes people riding bikes all
over the place Silver Diners everywhere
Silver Diners you know you see friends
is on TV and then it can just wash away
all of the troubles all of the troubles
there's no Ubers they're just bikes you
have to bike around everywhere get some
exercise the 90s I thought were really
depressing they were cool but it was
like because it was depressing people
made the best of it in the early 90s
Kurt Cobain was horribly depressed but
but Ian just imagine you're walking down
the street there's a guy and then you
know he waves to you and then all of a
sudden he's carrying he's carrying a
boom box on his shoulder and then you
hear the radio DJ say you know and now
the the big hit Inside Out by Eve six
sweeping the nation because people carry
boom boxes on their shoulders at least
that's what TV TV tells me thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time